full statement from the police there
they say a man from salford who we now
know to be
ryan giggs has been charged with three
offenses after police were called to
reports of a disturbance in the worsley
area
in november last year they say ryan
giggs has been charged with causing
actual bodily harm to a woman in her 30s
common assault of a woman in her 20s and
both counts relate to an instant on the
evening of sunday
the 1st of november well giggs of
chatsworth road in worsley has also been
charged with one
count of coercive and controlling
behavior between
december 2017 and november 2020 so
separate
dates for that he has been bailed and he
is due to appear at manchester united
magistrates court on wednesday the 28th
of april so that will happen
next week police say that they were
called at 5 past 10
on the 1st of november 2 reports of a
disturbance at that address
his home address and they say a woman in
her 30s was treated for
injuries at the scene so that is the
latest that we're hearing
in relation to ryan giggs a former
player of course for manchester united
and a
manager for wales that he has been
charged with
three offenses now relating to a series
of incidents at the end
of last year which resulted in one woman
being treated for her injuries